you already know what I want to talk
about non-stop only thing that's on yeah
how amazing it is to do
renovation the best thing to do New York
City is renovation and the most highly
competent and intelligent people on the
planet are those uh that do it the
contractors yeah honestly I think that
we should put them in charge of a lot
more than just renovating Apartments
because they're so incredibly efficient
at doing that that if we gave them
responsibility like I don't know running
the CIA or foreign policy I think that
they would it would be a fascinating
experiment yeah they've never anything
wrong this week Trump became my hero
when I found out that he absolutely uh
did refuse to pay contractors and like
put them out of business and I was like
I already like this guy but now he's a
genius now I get it I if you haven't
renovated a place and you hear Trump do
that you're like what a scumbag once you
renovate a place you go oh he's
Brave He's a brave person he's a
Genet this is yeah my life matters my my
apartment matters sit in what is other
contractors that they all suck why is
that the thing they don't all suck but I
think incentivized to suck their
incentivized go very slow break it down
so that way you have to pay them per day
and then you ask them hey what you do
today and then they'll just say a bunch
of words that you don't know so you
can't really verify it but they're
really just trying to stretch that [__]
as long as they don't have like
Integrity they're just not like look I'm
incentivized to do a bad job but maybe I
could this is the good thing about this
is truly why [__] gets built faster in
the South
illegals oh they got them here too say
but y'all got unions and [__] you got to
go those stupid [__] rules of
building Texas don't right to work state
there is no Union Mexicans building
everything and they're not they're
incentivized tr get to whatever the [__]
you know I me what they do they'll give
you like a little estimate they'll be
like ah it should only take us about two
months and about this mat and then six
months later they're like ah you know we
ran into some things yeah and every time
you make a little change it's a few more
thousand dollars even if they say that
they're going to take off money from
something that they [__] up they find
ways for you to pay for it in other
thing you went through some Renos yeah I
was doing my mom oh the place he used a
big contractor you don't remember this
but it is I was scamming people at Bron
for six years but it is a [__] yeah
dude it was supposed to
be took eight months it was supposed to
be two yeah how do you fix it so here's
so here's the tricky thing to fire them
get another another one in and then
that's a whole different process even
getting like work orders the a couple
things that are going on that I'm
realizing one um it's it's probably very
similar to like mechanics in that when
you drop your car off most of us have no
[__] clue what's wrong with a car how
to fix a car Etc so you're at the mercy
of their integrity if they have a lot of
Integrity they're going to be like hey
you just need break pads yeah if they
got some bills to pay that month so you
find a good mechanic you stick with them
I would drive like an hour and a half to
our mechanic cuz he trusted that guy
trusted him so in this business if you
know that you can make so if the
Arbitrage is what things cost you and
how much you can charge
and you know if somebody's naive like me
right or my wife we don't know [__]
jack [__] about what's going on then you
can make a lot of money other thing that
I realized now was like when you're
renovating if you cannot move water or
electric but mly water and gas if you
cannot move it don't what do you mean by
mov it so like changing the
system that we switch over from oil to
Electric it oh my God why would why
would switch over oil is better n it
like for a big house and especially the
old houses they lose heat a lot so it's
like wow the oil volatile so it's oh the
price of the heating because it was oil
HHH but what about your your stove is
still gas or that's gas okay good good
good because now you know all the new
buildings in New York that's you have to
have electric Trigg all right guys we're
going to take a break real quick because
in life there are certain bad habits
that we can't mention because of YouTube
rules and we don't want to break them
and get banned and if you have that bad
habit you need to check out fume okay
they look at the problem in a different
way instead of quitting cold turkey
which is incredibly hard why not just
make your bad habit a good habit fume is
an Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that just that does just that
like I said it's flavored Air instead of
vapor instead of electronics it's
completely natural natural and instead
of using harmful chemicals fume uses
delicious flavors you get what I'm
saying instead of bad it's good it's a
habit that you are free to enjoy that
makes replacing your bad habit easy your
fume right here comes with an adjustable
airflow dial you hear that click design
movable parts and fidgeting it's very
satisfying for any an anxiousness you
might be feeling just getting it out I
probably ruined the audio for the last
three seconds but I felt good while I
was doing it anyway fume is the move and
if you have this bad habit you got to
check this out it's got a nice weight to
it look at that Walnut looking finish I
don't know what wood that is I'm not a
real man but it looks beautiful this
right here is the Solano gorgeous
weighted nice carbon fiber looking ass
tip fantastic slightly softer finish and
right now is the best time truly the
best time to start your good habit with
fume because it's flagrant and we always
hook y'all up you will get an extra 10%
off when you use our code so head to
trif nume.com flagrant and use the code
flagrant for an additional 10% off okay
so when you start moving those pipes you
need to get crazy permissions and also
you have to really dig into the floor
below almost so now you're [__] up
your neighbor [__] and you know luckily
our neighbors are cool but if they
weren't you like really inconveniencing
them in a crazy way yeah and they're
going to renovate the floor above us
literally when we finish so we're going
to be sitting through that that's going
to be [__] miserable but I get they
do at the same time cuz they The woman
there is getting all her paperwork and
everything lined up so that so she's
renting it out right until she thinks
she has all that done and then starts it
she's smart but it's like and I get it
in New York everything you do like in
Texas you got your land you put a
kaleidoscope on your [__] thing you
put it it's no one's going to in New
York anything I do to my apartment could
really hurt the people below on top of
each other in New York and Texas were
next to each other exactly so like I get
why there is more rules but godamn bro
this [__] be [__] me up yeah it's
rough and it's like you don't want to
have to
like I I like to speak to to men in a
respectful
way you know what I mean cuz it's
condescending to be like why didn't you
do what you were supposed to do like I
I'm not your babysitter bro like and you
put up
cameras no that's like three months in I
was like [__] it I got Wi-Fi put up
cameras so now I could just see like are
y'all working are you working how did
how' you even think of that because put
you on to that no I just thought about
it cuz once it took longer than what he
said and I saw the price keep going up I
was like [__] this and I didn't see that
much going like happening so I'm like
and then I saw him there's a couple
times where just on their phone for Mad
long I'd be like yo dude what's up and
he's like oh my bad and then I had to
fire them you fired him got a whole new
team yeah and you told him you had
cameras in or no no I told him yeah new
team new cuz that's going to keep you on
your p and qes we had stuff stolen from
the bathroom in Italy so we put cameras
in every single room yeah oh yeah even
the bathrooms they'll steal they'll
steal the materials and be like I don't
know where it went get the [__] out of
here they have extra you're supposed to
return that and get that money back but
then they'll just be like up so this is
the tricky thing in a business where you
are incentivized to overcharge or not
disclose things so that you can make
more money you're always going to have
some form of scum yeah you know what I
mean like it's just like like for
example like and I don't maybe insurance
companies stopped this or whatever but
like what if doctors told you you had
more [__] wrong with you so that they
could chop you open more [__] it'd be
[__] up it's crazy but hospitals will
offer like anybody can get an m
because the point is you pay for the MRI
which is crazy expensive and then if we
find anything wrong with you and you're
going to find something wrong lowkey
they do that [__] yeah they are really
now is there any P I guess what I'm
trying to say is like if it found if if
we found out that doctors were doing
more surgeries than they really needed
to do they would get their license
revoked they would have all right NE
happened recently there there was a
place in Florida where they were giving
out a ton of like tummy tucks because
they were basically like really fast at
it and they're giving it to people that
didn't really need them they were just
being like ah you could use one like m
whatever and because they're fast at it
they were like pumping people in and out
getting them out before they were off
anesthetics like too quickly like
they're pumping people prescription
drugs and [__] son I had a uh small
example I broke this part of my finger
right here like kind of slopes down they
were like hey we can get you plastic
surgery blah blah blah it's going to
cost like $4,000 and then my mom was
like no we're not we're getting a second
opinion I was like Mom these are doctors
like they're telling me I need this she
took me to my uncle who lives in
Louisiana he had took me to like hand
specialists and they were like the
surgery is going to hurt it's going to
have recovery and it's probably still
going to be [__] up don't don't do the
surgery save $4,000 then she told me she
had a doctor tell her she needed a
hysterctomy didn't need one that's
[__] crazy before she had you that's
some racist [__] though uh after she had
me yeah cuz that's like a problem going
on in black and brown communities
they're like yo how do we stop these
[__] from having kids cut it
open H take out your uterus right yeah
yeah yeah and Mak sense they the doctor
told my mom she was going to be able to
have kids cuz with thid issue got a
second opinion they're like just take
this drug you'll be good it's crazy yeah
that to me is like like if she just
trusts my my mom who stopped going to
school at 15 years old yeah is in a
foreign country y if she just was you
know what I mean if she was like well
yeah the doctors are right I think
immigrants are going to because they
like the language barrier they're just
going to kind of trust me m yeah and
then I White Coat Syndrome you're just
like it was a doctor they got the white
coat on it's it must be true that's why
they give that [__] to [__] um
pharmacists
the white coat oh so you just trusted
them yeah cuz if it like a pharmacist
what do they do even yeah they do
nothing they count pills yeah but if
they got a white coat I feel like they
know what's going on in the pill that
[__] is fire white coat looks sick too
like it fits well it's got like your
name embroid on it I'm just Indian so I
know Pharmacists and I know how they
weren't too dumb to even think about
medical school like I could have been a
pharmacist no no like I you I mean like
think how [__] [__] you are I I
could do your job I literally my growing
up a friend of mine his mom was a
pharmacist were the white coat had like
the stethoscope for some like
look they be wearing it bro cospl
cosplay imagine this I pull up to Kmart
she's there I was like you what are you
doing she's like oh I work here I was
like what or this like working at the
Kmart Pharmacy that's so funny like you
go to kmar Every Day I'm saying the
attitude you give me to go to a [__]
CVS I was like this is crazy you ever go
there and they're like prescription is
not going to be ready for an hour hey
[__] it's 12
pills that's I'm right there you think
you're better than me yeah it's crazy
yeah it was wild no that is [__] up
how'd you break your finger I don't even
something I was trying to work on
something in the garage it's [__]
embarrassing I got a frail ass body
probably twinky Yodo something like that
going going a little crazy oh giving
them come
hits wasn't even but I wish I wish it
was something cool like that like
fingering
girls and not [__]
them